foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
happy monday
a lot of stuff happening
stuff over the weekend
we got to get to today
we have a special special pop-in
uh for today you guys know that we do
the po poc pop in
uh michael popock from legal af midas
touch legal af is going to join us
sometime in the first part of the hour
we're going to talk about this roe v
wade decision
and the fact that
brett kavanaugh
he feels violated
oh
what it must feel like
as a person who might go receive
a medical procedure at a planned
parenthood and have people yelling and
screaming at them demonizing them
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
the right wing's freaking out
because the majority ideology in this
country is being oppressed people's
liberty is being taken away their rights
are being stripped from them
and they and they think they think the
worst the worst that could happen is the
supreme court justices could hear people
yelling outside their homes they're
getting loud frankly they're getting
very loud very loud and then you have
false flags where i'm sure we're gonna
find out that right wing groups are
throwing molotov cocktails
into anti-abortion uh places
these uh these [ __ ] scumbag
headquarters where they wanna take your
liberty away these fascist headquarters
i'm sure we're going to find out just
like the bugaloo boys
at some of these protests where they
burnt buildings same [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh boy
oh boy it's a good morning it's a good
good morning good morning debbie from
salt lake amanda is here
kathy is here jay is here
reuben from facebook is here
now lisa from facebook crystal from
facebook mayo is here good morning mayo
now we have gloria we have christina
andrea kathy mike mike matt margie
brad
the audience is getting bigger and
bigger and bigger jill from facebook is
here janie from facebook is here david's
here midas robin is here good morning
minus robin
everyone is here this morning holy moly
you guys know we do this show live
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific
for two hours every single weekday
monday through friday
we air it on our youtube twitch and
twitter page so go follow us
at tony michael's pod you can go to
google and just type in tony michael's
podcast you'll find it all there or go
to thetonymichaels.com
and you'll find all the links
or go to youtube and just type in tony
michael's podcast you will find our
channel please subscribe to our channel
we also simulcast
as you know to the midas touch facebook
page we are partners of midas touch
and speaking of minus touch we have a
midas touch
extraordinaire
today for midas touch legal af michael
popock
he's going to be joining us here in just
a few
to give us the breakdown
of some of the things in the news in
particular the roe v wade decision uh
the draft decision also
also i want to ask him a few things
about the
the select public hearings the new york
attorney general and the civil case
where donald trump's being charged 10
000
a day and then the grand jury being
convened
and formed in georgia for election fraud
the actual election fraud that happened
in
2020 the actual trying to steal the
election
uh yes everyone we are going to have a
pop
poppin
everyone seems to be hungry they're
saying popock yum
[Laughter]
uh everyone thinks popock is a silver
fox we get it we you know we gotta we
gotta get it's monday
it's monday morning so
we gotta start fresh
with the silver fox michael popock from
legal af there's a lot of stuff in the
news though over the weekend you guys uh
seen that uh
there was another nazi rally excuse me
trump queuing on rally
did you see the video from this rally
oh my god
it was pouring ass rain it's porn ass
rain in the middle of a field these
[ __ ] morons are wading through the
mud to listen to the schlub speak
now
there's a lot of things about this rally
and i want to break it down today i want
to react as it were
to these fools
who crowded up in a field
and waited through the mud these [ __ ]
fascist pigs i actually i actually took
the
the video of them waiting through the
mud and put it to a certain song maybe
we'll maybe we'll play it here
um sometime during the broadcast when we
when we go through the trump rally
in pennsylvania i got a lot of thoughts
on why these trump rallies are happening
where they're happening and why this
kind of [ __ ] happens the way it happens
when you see these boneheads out in the
middle of this swamp
they're in a swamp they're in a swamp
drain this swamp that we're in please so
that we can
get out of the mud and go home and get
the hell away from you folks
it really is a sight to see even uh dr
oz was booed at this rally
uh so so we'll
we will um
we will break down the stupidity the q
anon stupidity at the at the uh the
rally the rally as it were
uh today also let's see what else do we
have um that is that is trending this
morning
um i know uh some people are are
concerned about the stock market um
here's the thing folks is
do you want to know what what will help
inflation
do you want do you want it do you want
to know what will help inflation if the
stock market goes down
like you can't you can't do both like
you can't inflate the economy
and then and then expect there not to be
inflation
like this is that that's that's how
that's that's how this
it's worked like that for uh
a long time
these people who claim to be free market
capitalists to claim to love our free
society our market our market-based
society
just to completely ignore how the market
works and how money works and how
inflation works and how the economy
works like literally the reason one of
the reasons why we have inflation is
because everything is so over inflated
including the stock market
you [ __ ] boneheads
come on pluck your head out of your ass
if you're complaining about inflation
and it's hurting you you should be
cheering that the stock market is is
going down a little bit is
re-correcting
here
that's what you should be excited about
that the stock market is actually
correcting it's it's not as inflated
what how in the [ __ ]
how in the [ __ ] don't we know these
things
we we can't even figure out that a
simple mask prevents particles
from releasing in the air so you can get
people sick
so it's not surprising that people don't
understand this simple [ __ ] about the
economy and money is that when the when
the stock market is over inflated
inflated inflation is going to be up
and when you raise the interest rate
when the fed raises the interest rate
it's going to beat back inflation and
the market is going to correct
rich people are excited
they are they're
completely excited about interest rates
going up folks they're not
people who don't have to borrow money
they are they are not fretting that the
interest rates are going up
they're not
look
everyone thinks an inflated economy is
horrible for the middle class that is
just categorically not a fact it can be
bad for the middle class
and it can be bad for the average
working american but inflation in
general
especially the type of inflation we have
where we have almost three percent
unemployment
where we were in a we were in a great
recession because donald trump [ __ ] up
the pandemic the response to the
pandemic the only reason why the only
reason why our economy is heated now is
because the democrats
delivered
for the american people not the
republicans they delivered for corporate
america
during the pandemic and then once joe
biden won the republicans like [ __ ] you
you're on your own
and the democrats
got it done
now they haven't continued to get it
done because of republicans
everyone wants to blame it on mansion
and cinema yeah sure are they a fault
course whatever but that's two
[ __ ]
there's 48 [ __ ] that won't move
for the american people
come on now
it's ridiculous
and now we see they're they're willing
to stand by why their party absolutely
[ __ ] buys and pays for supreme court
justices so that way they can strip away
rights from the american people
women in particular right now right now
it's women
soon it'll be the next group and the
next group and the next group and then
soon they'll come after you i even seen
an article someone sent me an article i
was on stuttering john's podcast
and greg o'lear was on there with us at
one point and i said right i think right
before great game on i said uh they're
gonna ban condoms like that's what
they're gonna do
they're gonna try to ban condoms all you
[ __ ] fragile white men out there that
are like oh well i ain't got nothing to
do with abortion so abortion sucks
and i don't give a damn because i could
never have an abortion even if i wanted
one
so [ __ ] women and [ __ ] their rights
they're coming after you too you [ __ ]
dummy
i can't wait for these [ __ ] these
trumped-up white males to walk into a
gas station to try to buy a condom and
they're like look they're banned
what they're banned oh my god
the problem is is a lot of these trumped
up fragile white males
i have no need for condoms
no need i mean
what are you gonna use a condom for
and i don't know
i mean
if you're a trumped-up white male
is anyone having sex with these guys
are they i don't know i
i couldn't imagine
[Laughter]
oh but brett kavanaugh he's really upset
and the right wing is really upset
that there's protest outside the
justices homes
really upset
how could you go and yell and scream and
be loud
that's just untenable
never in the history has anyone stood
outside a building and got really loud
and said really mean things to people
like as they were entering the building
called them baby killers and stuff
they've never done that they've never
shot and killed and assassinated doctors
before that's just something that the
pro-life movement could not
find
in their hearts to bull [ __ ]
this [ __ ] [ __ ] where we're
where they're equating
they're equating
the insurrection with people protesting
and yelling loudly outside the justices
houses get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ] no one believes that garbage
you were killing doctors you were
assassinating doctors
do you remember the name dr tiller do
you remember this guy was assassinated
in a [ __ ] church
they they murdered him in a church
the pro-lifers the christians as it were
you know
those types
come on
come on now
this isn't this isn't [ __ ] rocket
science
it's ridiculous we do not have to listen
to this garbage that people with
megaphones yelling and screaming outside
of justice's houses somehow is terrorism
they're not going they're not going to
the supreme court busting down doors
busting windows and threatening to hang
them out with a gallows that they've
erected
think about it think about the imagery
i just wonder i just wonder if brett
kavanaugh
had the [ __ ] guts to be a woman
had the [ __ ] guts to be a woman and
had to receive a medical procedure that
may save his life
because fascists like him won't allow it
i wonder if he could handle if he could
handle a bunch of people at a at a
planned parenthood yelling and screaming
that he was a baby killer i wonder if he
can handle that
brett kavanaugh couldn't handle two
seconds two [ __ ] seconds of being a
woman
not one of these fascists could
and that frankly
that frankly is the point here that
kavanaugh is so
is is so hurt
that people are are saying things
they're saying things in the megaphones
outside my home the truth
the truth that i want to strip away
people's rights
oh the horror get out of here with that
[ __ ]
i have a special guest for you you know
what time it is
michael popock how are you i'm doing
great
i look very tan am i less tan on the
main screen no no no you're you're fine
you're fine all right okay the painting
looks good everything everything looks
perfect
welcome back to the show you know
i've had your colleague karen agnipolo
kfa here uh several times since the last
time you came and i have to be honest
with you she's much prettier than you
are i know i know a lot of the people in
the chat they call you the silver fox
they've been telling you yum yum yum
this morning that you were coming on
they're very hungry this morning popock
um but but kfa she's she's much prettier
um than you are i do have to say i don't
mean to give you too much hell coming
back on the show but i enjoy having you
i enjoy having karen from legal af so
tell me what do you think about
this this uh protest of of the leaked
decision from the supreme court we
should probably start there since i was
just yelling and screaming about it
myself what do you what is your take on
some of this um these these these
snowflakes being really upset that
they're taking away americans liberties
and boy they really are scared that
they're that they're that they're
protesting about it well uh alito
anticipated this very thing which is the
expression by first amendment
of of people
and their opinion
about the supreme court voting to
overturn in the first time in 50 years
to take away actually the first time in
the history of the supreme court taking
away a right that they ex that that they
had extended to a group that previously
had needed protection in this case women
first time ever and he anticipated this
protest this
proper protest
in the streets when he said
we it does not concern us
what happens
after our decision
that does not
that does not dissuade us from making a
ruling under the u.s constitution what
happens outside the supreme court does
not concern us okay well if that's the
case
that when people take to the streets and
pick up pitchforks and torches
because of the apparent overturning of
50 years of settled law precedent
constitutional area and the stripping
away of a woman's right to choose a
constitutional right that had been
established not once but twice
it's twice settled law 1973 and 1992 in
the follow-up case of casey
and if they're going to change 92
honestly 1992 only really
makes even though it stripped
some of roe v wade away right it dialed
some of it back
isn't that really in the supreme court
um ruling doesn't that even more
codified into into the american fabric
that that is loved just by that decision
even though it turned it uh back away
from what roe v wade gave i mean that
really having two decisions is vitally
important and it makes it even harder
for them to justify them reversing it
doesn't it
the only just yes and for them to start
the decision
with saying that roe was egregiously
wrong on the day that it was written
right and we're just fixing it now
is really both intellectually dishonest
morally dishonest
and also
the scary part tony about the decision
as i've talked about on my own podcast
and a couple of other places the scary
part
is that by throwing away the rule of
precedent
the rule of starry decisis which is the
foundation for the u.s supreme court
since 1807 by throwing it into the trash
can which he does
and he says at one point in the decision
that the
the rule of precedent which is the
foundation for the entire supreme court
and has been since the first decision
that that it has the weakest hold over
constitutional analysis
are you are you effin kidding me to
paraphrase this show right
okay
precedent at this at the constitutional
level
is supposed to be abided by
in every way shape and form and they're
only supposed to overturn precedent if
there's a change in the law or in social
mores since they last expressed the
opinion of the court as recently as 1992
and what has changed
abortion has not gotten
worse medically people aren't dying from
it there aren't more abortions since
1992 there are less abortions since
1992. there isn't
more people that think abortion are
wrong if anything it has leveled up to
the point where now the majority of
people
are in favor of the woman's right to
choose so if none of those things have
changed since 1992
your your audience might be asking what
did change what changed is they got the
numbers
well yes well i mean i mean uh money got
changed into bank accounts and somehow
maybe one of the justices uh uh maybe
his name is kavanaugh maybe it's not i
don't know he he got some debt paid off
maybe that's how it happened maybe the
federal society you know uh put their
finger on the dial and and really um we
seen this week
that
even clarence thomas
says
oh my gosh this is egregious the the
our institutions are are are being
challenged and people the confidence in
them the person whose wife was involved
in helping helping trying to stoke the
insurrection
is concerned about our institutions
being being
compromised or or the confidence being
eroded are you kidding me is this is
this really the court that we think we
can deal with for the next several
decades do you think that is a do you
think that is the thing that that this
country is going to put up with well the
the gaslighting of america and of
american women has already started
both by the justices themselves with the
horror of the leak and oh my god our
institution is being attacked
um
following up with the republicans this
you know there's a leak of the senate
speaking of leaks there's a leak of the
senate republican committee's talking
points about roe v wade and the
overturning of the decision come the
election which is not the mothers and
the babies we won't go after the mothers
and the babies this doesn't remove
abortion as a choice it just returns it
to the states the state
where 23 of them are automatically going
to remove this as a right that is the
beauty of a constitutional right a
constitutional right is never supposed
to be removed and the rug pulled out
from under you because it's a
constitutional right lindsey graham took
to meet the press or one of the sunday
morning news shows and said oh it was
never really a right
it was a it was a fantasy right it
wasn't really there
so nothing got taken away this is the
gaslighting of america
and when you and then continue that that
thematic and they know no shame and they
know no i there's no such such thing as
irony to have ted cruz who refuses to
call the armed insurrection
the attack on the capital by 800 plus
people he refuses to call that what it
is right but the horror
of a few people standing out in front of
a supreme court justice with a bullhorn
oh my god that is violence that
oh my god
how could we ever survive in under
america where people were loud oh
oh my gosh
how could we ever survive listen don don
we like to involve some of the the
comments here and don here is oh he's a
favorite uh hate watcher here he said
tony just accused a justice of taking
bribes that's going too far hey hey don
hey don i want to remind you that the
justice that i am
that people out there have have accused
not me i'm just repeating what people
have said
people are saying don
what i'm what what you're saying that
i'm going too far is that i'm repeating
that maybe a justice took a bribe
but what not going too far is taking
away women's rights that same justice
that i am not accusing of taking bribes
i'm just saying that there's some stuff
out there in the uh the ecosphere
i'm saying i'm saying to you that it is
much much way too far that a debt
justice in particular would take away a
woman's rights with his decision after
he told us he would not do that well
continue continue with kavanaugh as long
as we're on because of your audience
we're on kavanaugh
why is alito quoting kavanaugh half a
dozen times in his own opinion when did
kavanaugh become the expert on civil
rights in america of all things that
wasn't that was a [ __ ] you from alito of
all the people up there and all the
people that have ever served on the
supreme court including real
conservative ones that i used to respect
like sandra day o'connor like rehnquist
and the others
like brent blackman and all the rest
that started out that way he quoted the
guy sitting next to him up on the bench
the one that got um who cried himself
speaking of crying and clutching pearls
who cried himself during his
confirmation hearing because boohoo
somebody said that he was mean to them
and sexually sexually attacked them
during college that's brett kavanaugh
that's one secondly brett kavanaugh of
all the people who testified under oath
he was the one that probably came
closest to lying under oath because the
others
were very uh were very careful in their
language they all said a version of the
following roe v wade is settled law
rovis they didn't say we're not going to
overturn settled law they just
acknowledge that it is that's like
saying like you know where the polls are
for skiing
and that's also the same thing as skiing
the course the way it's supposed to be
skied no that's just them recognizing
that subtle law he went a step further
he said basically under k as you said
earlier tony that the combination of roe
v wade and casey 20 years later
renders it a decision a juris prudential
precedent that should not be disturbed
so what happened brett
i looked around you saw you had the
numbers and it's time to clear the
shelves of all the things the federalist
society holds dear let's get right and
then what and what comes next now that
they've if this opinion becomes the
majority opinion which it's going to
this is now an open season open hunting
season to get rid of every
every right that's not written in stone
in the u.s constitution and just to
remind our audience the constitution was
purposely framed by the framers a bunch
of white guys were purposely framed not
to be a code book
it's not like section 132.48
of the constitution says this that or
the other thing this is a document that
you can publish in a pamphlet that's
supposed to be interpreted both by the
people its elected officials and the us
supreme court and to put and to put uh
meaning onto the words there and and to
find new rights that's we were taught in
law school in 91 right on the precipice
of casey when i left law school that it
was a living breathing document
that we mapped on to it
changing and evolving social mores like
we're not in favor of slavery anymore we
let like black and white people marry we
let we let gays and others
love who they want in their bedroom the
way that they want without government
standing there
with a with a flashlight okay
all of those now when you take starry
decisis and you throw it into the
dumpster
and you can say we can do anything we
want
we're six people wearing black robes
if that's the case why do we even need
cases we don't need cases to go up to
the supreme court they can just issue
every week
their edicts
their commandments of what the law
should be in the land right and and for
everybody tony
who says let's get a national referendum
on abortion we have a process for that
it's called a constitutional amendment
the problem is because they have the
numbers they only need to count to five
right we have to get to two-thirds of
the senate two-thirds of the house or
two-thirds of the states they only have
to count to five
five five middle-aged people sitting in
black robes you know at the supreme
court so let's let me tell you that that
is democracy and i believe in democracy
and um even though
even though it may seem like right now
that the pro-democracy people had their
backs against the walls um that system
of government that you just described is
the thing that will get us to a position
as long as we can get people educated
about what is going on and why it's so
important and there's a few other things
that i want to talk about i'm going to
bring gabe sanchez on because i know he
has a few questions for you too popock
um
but one one thing i do want to ask you
about is
um speaking of states rights because
that's the thing that they do they're
like oh states rights states rights
states rights well the state doesn't
have more rights than than the human
rights right like the state's rights
don't overrule the human rights like
that's not that's not exactly how our
constitution was written but speaking of
states rights
sony are we gonna let south carolina
re-enslave their black population
because well i mean it is the state's
right right it is the state's rights to
let white people own other human beings
i mean if that's what you want to do
then that's what you want to do but we
we had a whole thing i think it was
called um it was a war i forget the
president i forget the war there was a
whole thing we did i don't know it was
it was a while ago you know it's been a
while ago but we did it was it was it
before if it was before two weeks ago
it's well right
well right twitter twit it's not
trending on twitter or popular not
turning on twitter civil hashtag civil
war is not trying to control no no maybe
it should be maybe it should be but
speaking speaking of states rights
states do have some have rights and they
have rights to protect their interests
and we see down in georgia that the
state is protecting their interest in
their election when they're convening a
grand jury what is what is your take on
this grand jury and georgia and i'll let
gabe ask some questions too about maybe
the new york attorney general uh
exercising her state's rights uh to
protect their interest in taxes so if we
want to talk about states rights maybe
we should actually talk about the rights
that states do have well we've said
we've said on the legal af pod that ben
ben and karen and me too that the the
closest thing that we have to to a
criminal prosecution of trump
is not going to come from we predicted
this a long time ago karen's old office
at the new york uh the manhattan da's
office
it i still think it's going to come from
the department of justice through the
grand jury process in washington but the
the one who's quickest to it is fonnie
willis in georgia who now has her
special grand jury in place
uh that's going to be looking at
evidence to make and george is a little
different than other states it's going
to make a recommendation as to whether
there should be an indictment and the
sole issue she's looking at is one for
which all of us have heard the evidence
and it's the phone call that trump made
with mark meadows to brad raffensberger
which everybody now knows his name
pretty well because of the marjorie
taylor green who who knew who wanted to
know brad rafsberger before that but now
everybody knows him you know he's a he's
a poster child but he's also a
republican and he's running in his own
race against a trump appointed
former congresswoman who's now running
for that position so he's got the
politics of of that going on but look he
testified and he's been very honest that
he got a phone call from mark meadows
and donald trump that he recorded and
during the phone call donald trump said
can we just find 15 000 votes among
friends that's all and if you don't do
it it was like extortion if you don't do
it
you know bad things could happen
including jail you know
and so
the question is is that an unlawful
interference with the election process
in the state of georgia by a pres a
sitting president clinging to power to
try to get the secretary of state to
change the outcome of the election yes
or no this is not very hard for the for
the grand jury to either grasp those
concepts
um or to or to indict so
i'm still holding out hope that phony
willis puts on that evidence and that
gets that grand jury do you think do you
think though that that case could go
from being a georgia state case to being
a federal case i mean is that a
possibility so so what you're saying is
is if he's indicted in georgia because
georgia's interest is to protect their
elections right
speaking of states rights like states do
have rights to protect their interests
their interest would be uh georgia gabe
do you have a question about the state's
rights in new york with uh with the ten
thousand the ten thousand dollars a day
in contempt well i mean i think what uh
what are we at right now we're at a
hundred and
because it counts the weekend so we're
like 1 30 yes i want to say it's
everything it's every single day right
it's right yeah it's all natural days he
doesn't get a break from the week no no
yeah it's not just weekdays it's it is
seven days a week that thing even when
he's golfing even when he's gone yeah
it's an expensive day of golf
but yeah you you look at like you look
at georgia right yeah it's like 11 780
votes find them right it's very much the
same like to comey
i'm looking for loyalty here right like
that's the same you know it's uh i'm not
uh forcing this on you but i'm forcing
it on you you know that's like the well
i will
you did it you did it exactly right it's
the call to comey it's the call to to
zielinski to hold back 450 million
dollars in aid unless a hunter biden
investigation a prosecutor is open it's
the same there's no doubt like trump
couldn't listen to this and go that's
not me i don't do those things right all
he does i mean i think you could you
could you could play back the tape and
he would be so egotistical he'd be like
yeah that's me i said those things like
he would totally brag about it because
he would like i love the sound of my own
voice
right like that's the type of guy which
is insane to think about just from a
standpoint to be like we had a president
who did multiple times
tried to influence someone by holding
something back from them you know like
oh which is called distortion right
exactly it's like a little quick pro quo
here you do this i do this right
it is insane to think that we had a
present like that and then so you look
at
georgia i hope that you know you they
they assemble the grand jury and we
actually have a case there you look at
uh you look at new york you you've got
the ten thousand dollars today you look
at you know leticia james who's saying
like i'm gonna announce legislation to
expand the abortion access which would
go against right everyone's like oh
states rights well the state is acting
in their own right to protect the women
that they feel should have this right
that you took away this
fake fantasy right like again to go back
it goes back to the earlier statement
which was like
does that mean all the other rights are
fantasy rights like everyone's like i'm
a constitutionalist so you believe in
slavery you believe women shouldn't vote
like actually slavery was in the
constitution
right right right yeah yeah yeah right
now yeah the right to own other human
beings that was in our country that was
in our constitution exactly but like you
said like the the constitution is an
organism it is a living growing document
that is meant to be amended it is meant
to evolve like everyone who says
the otherwise i think are
ignorant or don't know anything about
our history as a country or the purpose
of the document but isn't that but
popock isn't that the kind of the the
crux of this of this fascist state that
they want it's like well we want to just
interpret the words that are there and
only the words that are there that way
we can dial back as far as we want is
that kind of right when you when you
you're exactly right when you and gabe's
right too when you start from
the premise that the federalist society
which all of these judges have kissed
the ring of in order to advance in their
careers from law school clerkships
federal lower federal court judge judge
positions and now the supreme court the
fealty that they showed to the
federalist society starts and ends with
the following concept
that you you only interpret the
constitution based on the literal text
of the constitution with reference when
it helps you to history
and not even our history yeah third 14th
century history 17 16th century history
on abortion what the hell is he talking
about who gives a [ __ ] what medieval
what medieval people who also believed
in leeches
uh
burning witches at the stake
putting them on racks in order to grow
them i mean who cares what a medieval
primitive people thought about when life
was conceived this is the problem that's
always been present in the abortion
right in the right to choose the problem
is the science that was baked into the
original decision
if they could have uncoupled the science
in brennan in uh in the casey in 1992
and they said look we're judges we're
not scientists we're not medical
professionals we're going to find that
under the right of privacy the
interpretation of the constitution
bodily autonomy that there is a right
for a woman
to terminate
whatever is inside her embryo fetus etc
at the appropriate time we're going to
leave the appropriate time to the
medical profession maybe to the states
to regulate
and that's going to be it
that that's in line with everything else
they don't legislate the exact way that
a state regulates gun control they don't
say
if it goes too far they'll find it
unconstitutional but they don't say
there and the constitution provides that
there shall be an id process and that
there shall be a cooling off and waiting
period that's left to the states why the
abortion right
hasn't just been declared to be we don't
like the science we can't figure it out
but there is a right and we'll leave it
to the states to regulate how that right
but it is a right gets executed here
they just said the science sucks it
sucked from the very beginning and we
and we are making a decision that should
have been left to the states we're
ripping the right away and that's it
that's only because they go back to
historically
not to current precedent current
precedent is these people have had the
right for over 50 years
and look at the ramification lower
abortion rates
more acceptance of abortion
and safer
that was the problem the problem is
women will get an abortion one way or
another to terminate an unwanted
pregnancy i thought we didn't want them
dying in underground clinics garages and
back alleys well we don't well we don't
we don't we actually care for another
living person or a human being
as opposed to
republicans who might you know again
republicans claim you know whether it's
under christianity or whatever they're
like i love i love thy neighbor you know
i will shelter you i will care for you i
will i will do all these things for you
and
until they need one or they're
and their kid needs one and then they're
on a flight to new york or california
which i don't worry about to go get you
know how many of these many of these
people have i don't know what your
audience is going to say about this do
they believe that out of 537 people in
the u.s congress there's not one affair
going on oh really yeah there's no
there's not one or or cocaine field sex
orgies i mean come on or a pregnancy
that somebody doesn't really want right
and what are they gonna do that because
they're rich and famous they get to go
offshore or they get to go to a state
like new york and california
we we should pass laws that say no no
elected official who voted against roe v
wade or any of them can ever go into our
state to have an abortion how about that
so so that's that's one
the second thing is when it when it
comes to uh when it comes to abortion
and the right and the right to choose no
one's pro-abortion this is why the
language has always been pro-choice and
then they took pro-life
it's not like i'm it's not like i'm
anti-life right okay it's not like i'm
pro-abortion or any of the people that
support it we're pro a woman's right to
choose
and we're against government compelled
forced pregnancy to term
that is what this word or to death i
mean here's the
here's the thing or to incest or to rape
right right because because we're
talking about uh because the science is
not is not out on this one like we know
we know that it is a clump of cells you
people out there still claiming that
life begins when the dude gets his oh
face is absolutely ridiculous and and
you sound ridiculous and the more
ridiculous you get the less support
you're going to have and this decision
is the most ridiculous turning back and
to think that they're going to stop in
red states because this is this is the
nonsense that that i think is um this is
the nonsense that they're going to stop
here right with red states oh we're
giving states rights and only and only
the states that want to ban abortion are
going to ban it that's all [ __ ]
they're not going to stop there they're
not going to stop their march to get rid
of women's rights because this is truly
not pro-life it is anti-woman they do
not want women to have the autonomy over
their bodies it has nothing to do with
the fetus it has nothing to do with the
baby they don't give a [ __ ] about
children in this country if they did
they would do something and get off
their asses about child hunger
we'll do it this way do it this way
um
if if this was uh i forget if it was a
schwarzenegger movie if men could carry
babies too oh that's what i was talking
about or
embryos or fetuses do you think this law
would have come down let's do that
you you think these old white guys would
have come down with they would have
found a way at their golf courses and
country clubs to come up with a way to
save the right to choose if it impacted
them or forced sterilization or forced
vasectomies if that was up for grabs
look i knew we were in trouble during
the oral argument when amy coney barrett
who never who was never a judge who was
only a notre dame catholic law professor
you mean she was unqualified
is that what you're saying who has seven
children
when she who who believes in her and by
the way i'm fine with believing in your
faith somebody on your somebody on your
channel i don't know who it is um
i don't know they implied that i'm the
devil it was like speak of the devil
here's popak all right
by the way the devil is the devil is
pro-choice i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
put that out there yeah right you know
start that twitter trend all right now
now having having said that i don't even
know where i was having said that
amy coney bear at handmade amy coney
barrett during the oral argument
i mean totally apropos of nothing like
from beyond left field like from a whole
another planet
actually asked her question i think she
asked one
aren't there places where a baby can be
dropped off like at firehouses
i'm like okay stop
okay stop
so
because there are
there are laws on the books and there
are in most states that allow a woman
who's given birth to a child that she
does not want without any questions
asked
to as long as the child's not
jeopardized to kind of leave it on a
doorstep that is the substitute for a
woman's autonomy and right to choose
well she's just taking it back to moses
you know she's like put it in the thing
drop it down the river well that was
saturday night live right i thought i
thought she did a great job
did a great job as amy coney barrett
just do your nine just do your nine
months just drop drop the baby what's
the big deal right yeah
drop it did you guys seen the opening
the cold open it was it was it was a
good cold open it was a good cold open
which is it is it is you know it comes
back to one of these things where it's
like
they're not making anything up obviously
they're exaggerating some jokes but this
is literally oh let me let me call on
this old
thing that was done from medieval times
and i'm going to quote this as something
that should be used in 2022. and then
why don't you quote all the things from
medieval times right yeah exactly
i know people
people people popping in right now tony
are probably thinking are they talking
about the place with the big turkey legs
medieval times
no
well what they want to take us back to
medieval times and let me let me prove
it to you before you go pop i've got a
clip that i like to play here um
constantly and the reason why is because
he really is the leader of messaging of
the republican party you've heard of the
america first um language right you've
heard of america first language well of
course uh uh pretty sure charles
lindbergh used that it's and it's also a
pro-nazi language marjorie taylor greene
and
uh
matt gates charlie kirk and yeah
they should look up the history of
america first and when it was first used
in this country
maybe they did look it up and they're
like yep this is exactly yeah that's us
so this is this is nick fuentes do you
know nick fuentes is uh he actually has
this little logo down here at the bottom
it's called america first this is the
this is the guy who's an anti-semite he
holds nazi rallies and he calls them
america first rallies and he's the guy
at the ny uh um the fdny was in the news
this weekend for america first guys
yelling at protesters this is that guy
this is his their leader this is the guy
that marjorie taylor well if i could get
it i think we have copyright
infringement on af by the way that looks
a lot like legally that looks like my
legal lawyer uh oh popock the lawyer's
on it here he's he's gonna file a brief
listen so so this person nick fuentes is
the one that marjorie taylor green went
to his rally um his nazi rally and she
spoke and then she didn't know him she
couldn't recall you know she didn't
recall a lot of things but i want to
show you what nick fuentes their their
master of messaging here has to say
about women and abortions and what the
punishment should be listen very
carefully the woman should be put in
jail too
they should all go to jail a hundred
years for the doctor a thousand years
for the woman that's what i say this is
their master of messaging pope why is it
always a guy that looks like he's never
had sex in his life he hasn't he's never
had he's never it's always that guy
right who looks like it and they're like
i i chose to be celibate right right
right
oh yeah yeah you chose okay i've been
choosing since i was in the fifth grade
great right
is there anything you'd like to plug
before you go i know you probably have
to bounce here soon what would you like
to plug plug anything that you'd like oh
all right thank you so uh every
wednesday and saturdays we do legal af
on the midas dutch network where we look
at similar to what we're doing here but
we sometimes we bring in some guests we
look at six or eight um real time
stories from that week at the
intersection of law and politics that's
our wheelhouse that's our lane
and i either do it with ben misalis one
of the founders of midas touch a civil
rights lawyer along with me or i do with
the midweek edition which is a slightly
shorter edition with karen friedman
agnifulo a former prosecutor in the
manhattan da's office and we really look
at every story from abortion anything
trump jan 6
anything related to
you know things that are in the news
that are really important the
prosecution of the gen 6 people and we
and we call it like it is if we call
balls and strikes we don't blow smoke or
sunshine we do it from a democratic
progressive standpoint no doubt but you
know i'm there you know to really
um get under the hood and tell our
listeners what the facts are our
audience so they can go out into the
streets and with bull horns or otherwise
and debate these issues with real
knowledge and real facts we have um on
the twitter community we have a legal af
twitter community that people can join
where i post
information in in and out of each show
could be the actual lawsuit it could be
um the decision the order the leaked
order whatever it is we'll put it all
there so thanks for letting me do the
plug and you know we love coming on this
show too yeah well uh as everyone knows
out there we simulcast to the mind is
touch facebook page and pop i know
you're you appear over there several
times a week on the midas touch facebook
page as well to their other properties
um so go go follow legal af go download
it um go to facebook go to youtube uh
watch legal af and
our our listeners know you and they also
know kfa um you know kfa came and she
helped us um break down the marjorie
taylor green hearing that day so anyone
who wants to go watch kfa do that um
we've got that on our youtube channel
just go the tony michaels podcast on
youtube and see kfa do that but go
follow legal af um it's worth watching
worth the list did i hear or did you
tell me pre uh pre pre-party that uh
you're gonna be doing the uh jan six
committee hearings
real
gavel to gavel in june is that true
it sounds it sounds like well me and
gabe uh want to live stream just like we
did the marjory taylor green with
commentary that um um that day we want
to do that for the public hearings of
the jan 6. so our plan is to live stream
the gen 6 with commentary from gavel to
gavel to make sure that the not just
um our audience sees the hearing itself
but also gets live commentary so we
would love to have you kfa and ben
from legal af come and give us some of
the legal breakdown as those
as those hearings uh uh go on and we
live stream them um just like we did the
marjory taylor green so you're you are
welcome to come and and give us your
commentary yeah i'd love to do that yeah
i watched it i watched it with karen
and i know uh and ben would do it too so
i think well it's going to be
a week-long
must-watch tv for democracy for for the
republic's survival i know everybo i
know the marjorie taylor greens and the
republicans and some of them are
watching the show are like i loved her
comment it was only one day
it was just one day
it was just one insurrection on one day
that's all right like pearl harbor
like hiroshima was one day right right
harbor
ripped it just one day it was just one
day right yeah well yeah you know one
day at a time i guess so we'll we'll get
to the bottom of it with the uh jan six
public hearing so audience out there
listening pop is just broke news here on
uh the tony michael's podcast is we will
be streaming live
the public jan six hearings uh from the
select committee in popeye sounds like
he's gonna be joining us sounds like i'm
going to yeah i'm going to join i'm
going to have to join you that's
fantastic that's fantastic well we look
forward we look forward to those
hearings and you joining us in your
commentary uh audience stick around we
got more for you with the tony michaels
podcast pop thanks for coming on we
always enjoy having you back tell
everyone here thank you
yeah tell us that tell everyone at legal
af we said hi okay oh we will thank you
everyone stick around we'll be right
back thanks guys good luck thank you
cheers
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lib loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] a [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
michael pop the silver fox from legal af
[Music]
get the rock music going
yeah in this corner in this corner ding
ding ding ding we have michael
the silver fox pop
i don't know maybe yeah that's how we
that maybe that's how we introduce them
next time we usually do the bing bong
the
where it's like
in this corner you know just have a big
just have a nice wrestling belt that
just says right right legal af you know
the champion the champ the church is
here
yeah there we go i don't know everyone
likes blowpock i don't know i i gave
popocal when he first came on because
everyone in the chat was like yummy
yummy yummy pop they were hungry gabe
they were really old they were like
they had the monday nipples they wanted
a silver fox sandwich or something i'm
not sure what all that means in the chat
i don't know i have no idea but but
here's the thing i told him i did tell
popock because popock is a good-looking
fella right he's a good-looking fellow
but i hope someday i'd age like that
yeah well right yeah you had the nice
silver hair i mean you know the beard
the hair yeah i you know i've slowly i'm
growing yeah yeah well
maybe one of these days when you grow up
gay yeah maybe one of you i think in
like 20 or 30 years i'll finally have a
beard right well just maybe it's that
soda stream i don't know maybe that has
can you do something
my beard has grown has grown more
uh since since i've been having so maybe
there's not causation or correlation i
don't know
just like those republicans and the and
the supreme court aren't doctors or
scientists right
everyone do your own research i guess
maybe maybe maybe um
but i did i did tell popock i was like
kfa
is uh much prettier than he is i think
so um i love having women women's voices
on here and pobac kind of broke the news
that we're going to be live streaming
the uh
the hearings and we want to have a lot
of folks on to give commentary and i
can't wait to hear
what kfa has to say that day about these
yeah she was great during the emergency
screen hearing yeah she was she was
opening up doors that we would never
even be able to find right or unlock um
with her with her legal analysis and her
background so everyone everyone go
follow kfa and popoc and legalaf on
twitter um and be sure to catch our
select committee public hearings our
special coverage as it were because
we're going to try to live stream just
like we did the marjory taylor green
hearing um i'm going to try to not go to
the bathroom the entire day see how long
i can go you know people thought i
didn't even go to the bathroom that day
that is true and i may or may not have
i'm not going to confirm or deny
tony set up a whole thing
bottles underneath my desk no no no no
it's like it's like um um what a
catheter yeah well
what no on um
uh big bang theory when they're waiting
in line for the movie and i have never
watched that show
oh
sorry i didn't i didn't watch
it number one comedy
wait wait a second wait a second are you
is this breaking news that gabe sanchez
has never seen
never seen a big episode get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] you are full
of [ __ ]
never seen it
[Laughter]
all right all right folks we're gonna
have to find us another co-host this is
absolutely wow
that's not i just i'm just kidding cbs
it's a it's a red network you know it's
meant to really go for the red states oh
is that uh yeah red pill over there cbs
cbx and fox are red channels oh they're
red just like abc and nbc are so is that
why you didn't watch the big bang theory
or uh no i just didn't think it was
funny
oh
what sorry just it wasn't it wasn't my
sitcom i didn't i didn't continue to
watch it all the way to the end i
watched the the first season oh so you
didn't like it anymore
well i mean it get kind of redundant and
ridiculous
it's kind of like everything else okay
well here's the thing here's the thing
all the best all the best ones like
seinfeld nine seasons i think i i think
uh friends is what 10 seasons you go
past you go past nine eight nine ten
seasons you're just overstaying your
welcome is the way i look unless you
like the symptoms
i mean you know you get to a certain
point and you become uh
approved for you get syndication right
more money that's the that's the deal
that hundred episodes right no i will
say always sunny is like on season 16
right now they're going for the record
but they do have a good they do a good
job of making sure that the comedy keeps
hiding well see i didn't even know they
were still on see that yeah that shows
you that shows you of how it wears out
over time and how is it wears out over
time um
speaking of wearing out over time
i don't know you know my transitions
here um what what do you think about
what's your opinion on these protests in
front of these justices houses
apparently
uh i
this is what i think i think
that people complaining about people
showing up to kavanaugh sauce a house i
i i
i think it's totally fine i think it's
totally fine they're just getting into a
little good trouble they're not causing
any harm right obviously that's that's a
problem right there but if you look at
if you look at brett kavanaugh and every
one of these other supreme court
justices that are trying to or or
republicans the gop they are violating
other people's rights right it only it
starts here and it's going to continue
on to where it's like oh i'm going to go
into your house because
uh
we you know we believe we heard
that uh you were pregnant and we don't
want you get up you know an abortion i'm
not saying it'll go that far but i am
saying like the extreme of feeling
violated in your own home imagine how a
woman feels their own body feels
violated because they through whatever
means now have to have a child that they
don't want they don't don't feel like
they have the resources or they don't
have the the proper support to help
raise so they say i want an abortion
there's nothing wrong with that but
according to the gop and the supreme
court
yeah they're just uh
they have to have the kid right what
what did what did alito say he said
domestic uh
domestic supply of infants well i mean
you know you gotta have inventory gabe
you gotta have inventory
and we can't we can't we can't we can't
have people being loud
on public sidewalks in front of
justice's houses that is just
intolerable in this country we cannot
have people holding megaphones and
saying things that make these fascists
uncomfortable get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] look and frankly frankly
they're trying to equate people being
loud on a street in front of a justice's
house because they're trying to strip
away people's rights away from them
right
equating it to an insurrection look if
it were the insurrection people would be
going to the supreme court they would be
breaking down the doors breaking windows
uh erecting a gallows in front of the
supreme court and threatening to hang
the justices they are not doing that
that is not a thing they're doing
they're not going in the supreme court
they're not what are you are you saying
that these people are actually
protesting yes i am violent
safe you know you know what scares do
you know what terrifies fascists do you
know what terrifies them absolutely free
speech terror yet yeah and protest
i mean it is it is the thing that
absolutely terrifies him and has for
years and someone sent me uh anonymous
has this uh i want i want to play this
anonymous uh posted this video from
telecomics canada um
i'm not sure it is a rendition of woody
guthrie do you know woody guthrie is you
know what he got three is
that name sounds familiar so woody
guthrie is a folk music um he wrote folk
music and he had a guitar and the guitar
on the guitar it says
this machine kills fascists he wrote do
you know the song this land is your land
oh yeah this land is my land
from the new york islands i i'm from
beginning it wrong
right so that that is that that woody
guthrie song
is a response to
um
god bless america right so uh woody
guthrie wrote that song in response to
um
god bless america but here's the thing
here's the thing is he also wrote a song
said um all you fascists are bound to
lose all you fascists are bound to lose
and here is a great rendition that
anonymous had posted of all you fascists
are bound to lose let's listen
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
bye
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what a fantastic what a fantastic
um rendition of woody guthrie's
all you fascists bound to lose i think
it's actually you bound to lose all you
fascists are bound to lose
but what what a what a fantastic song
and and again
you know it it is it is a situation
where we can't get rid of fascism gabe
we've talked about this before this is
an idea right so like you can't kill an
idea right
um the only thing you can do is present
the ideas that are
uh obviously
uh in a competition
of of progression and to make sure that
all people have equality and equity and
that's what they're terrified of that's
why they're scared that people are
standing in front of these justices
houses
with microphones is because they know
that weapon is much bigger the the video
we just played you've seen women
protesting you see men protesting for
women's rights you've seen people with
megaphones you see people with
microphones guitars and music right that
that
that is the weapon that moves progress
that is the weapon that sways decisions
now
i'm not saying i'm not saying that there
is going to be a
a a difference in the draft decision
from the actual decision but i almost
bet there's a lot of differences when
they actually release this decision i
still think they're going to overturn
roe v wade right i still think that is
their aim they're going to do everything
they can to possibly do that but i do
think
i do think that they will try their
damnedest they're damnedest
to make sure to make sure
that there are is language that we are
poking fun at that we are that we are
clowning that the american people will
not put up with with protests they're
going to make sure that doesn't appear
we have a super chat and gabe we got a
new animation that
i want to do
here we go here's our new super chat
look at this
oh
thanks for the super chat mj
thank you for the super chat mj she says
all you fascists bound to lose um we
will try to play this song more and more
uh what a great song
and i hope everyone out there spreads
that spreads that video around take it
retweet it quote tweet it
embed it whatever you can do put it on
other social media platforms whatever
you can do i i plan on going and posting
it later on instagram uh so it can
spread around over there we should
spread that that video around like a
disease
and and infect all these fascists with
what with what will truly happen
when they come the other i mean you you
look at these people who are like don't
protest that's not how you should
protest like tony where have we heard
this type of response before right the
people who don't want you to protest
right are the ones by the way are also
the same people who are saying first
amendment right you have the freedom of
speech freedom religion freedom to you
know to to to assemble protest like
these people that you know care for the
first amendment care for the second
amendment you know i i look at this and
i say
they're also the same people that want
to restrict your first amendment and
what you can say and what you can do now
you know you look at the person
everyone's like oh how dare they how
dare they
literally his neighbor is the one that
has assembled this group of people to
peacefully protest outside his home
they're not on private property they're
on public property okay they're on the
sidewalk they're on the street
right they're not on his on his lawn
they're not at his door they're not
inside his living room
you know you you look at what's
happening here and
to quote the the woman the the the
neighbor right she's like i organize
peaceful candlelit vigils in front of
this house we're get we're about to get
doomsday so i'm not going to be civil to
that man at all that's right [ __ ] him
right you look at that again it is a
complete violation of of women's rights
to say
you actually don't have the amount of
control and autonomy that you think you
do as a woman right you can't quite make
the decisions
because we don't feel like you you
should right we don't feel like
uh you have the right to make those
decisions right what you were born with
isn't actually yours it is ours it's the
government's right this is the same
group of people that say oh oh that's a
that's big government we gotta we gotta
knock that down they're tyrannical
they're overreaching they're coming into
our homes they're taking our money all
this stuff again the same group that
says yeah government you can reach into
a woman's
private area and control who has what it
is
you say
the government wants to control her
[ __ ] and what she does with it and what
she doesn't do with it and her body why
are they so [ __ ] focused on it and
folks they're gaslighting the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of you they're saying oh this
won't be that bad this is just the
states this is just the states deciding
whether they want abortion on that's all
[ __ ]
they're they've these states have done
decided that you do not have this right
and let me play you from tennessee
tennessee holler has this video here and
uh popock actually alluded to it earlier
there is uh i believe 23 to 25 states
that have trigger laws what that means
is a trigger law is a law that is on the
books that as soon as roe v wade is
struck down from the supreme court that
it they set it all up they absolutely
bans abortion within a certain amount of
days from that state they don't have to
do a [ __ ] thing they don't have to
lift a finger
so to say to say that oh it's just gonna
be the state's ability to make this
decision that's [ __ ] they've done
made this decision they've done they've
done wreaked havoc on women's rights
inside the states these laws are just
laying in weight laying in weight to
take away your bodily autonomy and folks
don't think they won't do this for other
rights they're coming after them they
are going to come after them
the only the only thing that gives me
confidence is the 19th amendment the
women's right to vote is is an actual
constitutional amendment but don't think
they won't come after it don't think
they won't try to bang it up don't try
to think they won't assault and rape the
right of women to vote
and make them make them carry that baby
to term for sure let's listen to what
they say in tennessee about these
trigger laws let's listen this
legislation would take effect upon the
this was passed in 2018
i believe no 2019 to be known for
protecting our children proud to see you
staying to the gap for the unborn here
because this bill truly does protect a
human being is going to give a violent
rapist
the right to choose the mother of his
child
this is gloria johnson i'm she's the one
who retweeted this
uh this is the one uh this is the she is
the representative um that has been
speaking out about this issue and also
speaking out about some of the bills
some of the gross bills the
anti-lgbtq and some of the bills where
they're trying to marry children in
tennessee as well i just want to point
that out but this is uh for if you look
at the date here let me pull down the
banner so you can uh see this here it's
the date here on the um the broadcast is
4 22 19. so this is this is uh
is this the earliest that we've seen
because i i
probably doubt this is the earliest i i
would imagine that these people
obviously have been planning this to say
whenever this does get overturned at the
supreme court level we've got these
other things that are contingent it's
all conditional to say if this then that
and this is obviously 2019 but i
wouldn't be surprised if there was stuff
earlier i just didn't know if there was
like specific dates for earlier times
when somebody put in a conditional
trigger law
um
similar to what we're seeing here uh
cindy says the missouri's trigger law
was written in 2019 we'd have to look
that up but it sounds like it sounds
like all this was done
um after after uh brett kavanaugh
cried
and gorsuch yeah so let's listen to the
rest of uh this argument arguing back
and forth of this trigger law you
do not trust a woman to make her own
health decision you do not
believe that women are equal whether a
woman should have a rapist baby or not
vote for this bill and you have a wife a
mother or a daughter
something's wrong which one would i have
given back if i had decided to have had
an abortion where will it end that's a
child if it were a medical decision
it would not impact the ability
of another person
okay this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] here
andy holt um
a republican from dresden i don't know
if he's still an elected official or not
he shouldn't be dog catcher anywhere
even obviously he doesn't he doesn't
value uh someone's medical decisions at
all
you you [ __ ] people especially this
this don cobin and we gotta we got a
hater
yeah don we got a hate watcher over on
facebook and everyone everyone thinks oh
all these shows they're just they just
get they're just lying uh don says tony
show some proof just saying it doesn't
make it true i don't know what the [ __ ]
proof you're wanting you're done but
other than the proof of this guy right
here he doesn't think medical decisions
exist
when it comes to the things he believes
right if he believes that it's not a
medical decision then it's not don what
happens when he tells you that your
medical decision isn't a medical
decision you people really are cheering
on the fascist you really are fascist
yourselves but you have no idea what it
means don you have no clue what it is
going to mean for you i mean do you
think they're going to stop at women
come on let's look at arizona let's look
at arizona right you got a gop senate
candidate who is endorsed by peter thiel
not a great guy obviously and blake
masters right he's running on an
anti-abortion platform and what did he
say he wants to ban
birth control on a state level
what would that mean
you know uh that would be any sort of
contraception for the woman oh what does
that also mean it means [ __ ] condoms
all right and i said i've been saying it
that they're gonna try to come after
your [ __ ] right to make a medical
decision because wearing a condom isn't
a [ __ ] sexual decision it is a
medical decision that you're making
about your health and well-being while
you're having sex with someone and if
you get an std
sorry dude right that's on you yeah
right like there are reasons why you
have a condom not just to get pregnant
but hey maybe there's an std and i don't
want to catch it because i want to be
safe and i want to make sure that i
don't have a problem like i don't get
syphilis that leads to neurosyphilis and
i go crazy like [ __ ] al capone or
potentially donald trump but you look at
this right now and these are things that
are safe right if we remove these from
high schools to say like we're not going
to teach about safe sex education we're
not going to teach about this
you're going to find people that go out
there and they have accidental
pregnancies they're forced to have
babies they're put into a life-crushing
debt like then these children and
themselves uh are raised in poverty
you've got child poverty and like uh in
in food stricken areas like it's it is a
there's a compounding effect that
happens throughout someone's life if you
are forcing this decision on not only
the parent but also on this unborn clump
of cells okay that's what happens there
is a domino effect it is a butterfly
effect that will go throughout that next
person's life the trauma and stress that
they have to experience because this
dude right here andy holt decided you
know what women can't make the decision
and neither can doctors and all that
should be done is made by us the
legislator and we say if roe vs way is
overturned then what ends up happening
is you have to have the baby and you
have to raise it and we won't give you
funding we won't give you resources we
won't give you support you got to do it
on your own you got to pull yourself up
by your bootstraps and the baby too
you know everyone on facebook
and even out there on youtube don don's
really hurt by what i said
he's really hurt he he probably
he's he's a brett kavanaugh type he's
probably cries in his beard i've been
polite to you and everyone else i'm
happy to debate you but if you insult me
bye well guess what don you're a fascist
and if you don't like being called a
fascist if you don't like being called
the fascist that's your problem that's
your problem not mine i i'm you can call
me whatever you want to call me in the
chat but listen when when we talk about
issues here i am not going to cower away
from anyone especially this andy holt
[ __ ] in tennessee i would love
to have andy on i would love to eat his
[ __ ] lunch i would love to insult him
by calling him a fascist because that's
what he is i'm not insulting you by
calling you what you are and what you
what you aspire to be get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] and don if you
gotta go see you buddy if you're that
much of a snowflake oh go go go with
cavanaugh and cry in your beer the [ __ ]
out of here these people are supposed to
be manly men go tan your balls don let's
listen to let's listen to ball tanner
here andy holt
to live or not to live i have a minor in
reproduction so this is a great game he
has a minor reproduction that child is
made in the image of god at no point is
it just a glob of cells you guess you
could just ask yourself do i believe in
science or not a minor in reproduction a
minor in animal sciences i'm not sure
qualifies the overall so this guy
apparently andy holt has a has a uh he
has a degree in animal science and he
considers that a degree in in um
in in
is that a legitimate thing or is that
one is that something he is trying to
rebrand
as reproduction
well i don't i don't i it is hard it is
hard to understand what these q anon
these q anon [ __ ] think okay well here
i will tell you this i was raised as a
catholic and so were you but i remember
going through sex education in catholic
grade school and you want to know what
we learned we learned that masturbation
was a sin okay you didn't even have to
meet the egg with the sperm to say
that's a baby right it didn't have to
have a conception have you ever seen the
video reception have you seen the monty
python every sperm and sacred oh my god
that's beautiful every sperm is sacred
you've never seen that no oh my god
jesus gabe where have you been you're
like
they censored us in our catholic grade
school they're like you can't do this
but but i'm telling you right now like
this is something where they said
if you masturbate it's a sin because you
are killing babies right this is how far
it goes i didn't even have to meet the
sperm with the egg to actually make a
baby right that clump of cells i didn't
have to i didn't have to do that i did
it on my own
so for every man out there that's
jerking it and working it right
you know [ __ ] tubing and lubin
whatever it might be they're coming
after you huh they're coming after you
i'm just saying
if you're if you're sitting down there
tubing and lube and jerking and working
like spraying and praying like
maybe the josh hollies of the world
should be scared uh sherry thank you for
the super chat here it's important for
men to stand with women on their bodily
autonomy she said thanks guys no no
cherry you do not have to thank me we
will always stand for equality equity
and the liberty of all people i don't
give a [ __ ] who you are even don in the
chat who thinks he's a tough guy
um
even donny down there who got his
feelings hurt because i called him a
fascist um i believe in his right to be
a fascist folks i believe in the right
of don
don and all all who are like him to be
fascist i believe in their right to hold
those crazy ass medieval beliefs that
that the absolute bone-headed tree of of
trying to prevent other people of being
who they are what they are and to make
the choices they want to make
i am okay with them being a fascist in
this country because here's what i
believe folks i believe there's a lot
more people out there that are for
democracy that are for their individual
liberty
that are for their individual rights and
they know when when the government
whether it be the states rights or the
federal rights or the supreme court are
are fascist everywhere it doesn't matter
who's taking their rights away when they
start coming after them they won't stop
at them they will come after you that is
the [ __ ] point here is that we have
to stand with all people women children
men
people of all religion i'm an atheist i
think religion is
it's a really american christianity is a
disease that has rotted our country but
i believe in the right to people to
believe in their religion
it is we cannot take rights away from
people human rights away from people and
the the ability for a woman to make a
choice about her bodily autonomy and her
medical decisions about her body is her
choice and it is a human [ __ ] right
and you start stripping their human
rights away they'll come after you and
it is so important for equality and
equity and progress in this country that
we not strip away anyone's human rights
that is important let's finish this
video here and then we'll we'll see what
i got some more video i want to show you
overwhelming
hypocrisy of this given the talk about
if we believe in science from people who
don't believe in global warming and then
we want to talk about being pro-life but
we don't believe in providing people
access to health care after they're born
all right 69 24 days i hereby declare it
past
so this is uh by tennessee holler again
this is a situation uh let's give him
let's give him credit here for being on
the show thanks for thanks for the video
and for anyone out there i see people in
the comments that are like oh this guy
you know she he should go or whatever
it's like we're not going to ban this
guy no don can say whatever yeah we're
not yeah
he wants to say as long as he's not
saying racist [ __ ] bigoted [ __ ] in my
comments he'll stay he'll be a hate
watcher he'll be here every day folks
and maybe one of these days don will
pluck his head out of his ass and
realize what the [ __ ] we're saying yeah
the [ __ ] that we're saying makes us
because don probably thinks he's manly
and all this tucker carlson [ __ ] um
you know he repeats all the fox news oan
and
stuff but he hey man i'm i'm sure don's
a free thinker right absolutely he's a
free thinker right he's probably looking
for himself he probably i mean he he
knows enough to watch this show and he
knows enough to come uh participate
watch the word you said come there okay
well you know i don't want to offend don
by saying too too much sexual stuff it
might offend his ears um here is
something that definitely will offend um
don
uh in the chat here um this uh i'm not
sure this guy's first name and it
doesn't say here representative rice
he's a republican from tennessee um he
is from the seventh congressional
district he was uh
the the representative for the seventh
congressional district in in tennessee
excuse me south carolina excuse me this
is south carolina
um
he tennessee holler has this that's why
i keep saying tennessee uh south
carolina representative rice of the 7th
congressional district of south carolina
was the sitting congressman
when he voted
to impeach and remove donald trump
um from office after the january 6
insurrection now i i posed a question
this morning gabe i said
um this is worth talking about imagine
imagine a reality because this reality
does not exist right now but imagine a
reality
where we could have conversations
if the republican party viewed the
january 6 violent insurrection this way
okay this is very important folks this
is why this is why we can't have these
conversations i'm not saying we sh we
should have them we can't have
reasonable conversations about other
things like other things like how can
you take how can you take seriously what
a a person who believes that the violent
insurrection was a tour event right
right that it was a bunch of tourists
normal day but they weren't trying to
overturn our constitution that they
weren't trying to take over they didn't
just all of a sudden design build
transport and rebuild a bunch of gallows
or rather one gallon to hang the vice
president of the united states if he
didn't do what they wanted him to do
which was to go against the constitution
rip it up and wipe his ass with it what
were they what were they intending to
use the gallows for exactly like even if
even if it was just a prop still kind of
sends a message you guys are pretty
[ __ ] crazy right so representative
rice here stands by his vote
in this debate and he's debating other
republicans here in the primary debate
but listen to what he says if the
republican party believed this through
and through in their bones imagine
just imagine the actual conversations
and the things we could do in this
country but we can't because they're
fascist my friends i was there on
january 6th
i wasn't absent
i was there
i i saw the bomb squads defusing bombs
i smelled the tear gas
i was on the house floor when the glass
was breaking when they were trying to
break down the doors
when we evacuated i passed capitol
police officers who were beaten and
broken and being pulled from the lines
when we got to the spot where we were
evacuated
fox news was on tv
i was getting calls from back here from
friends and the news and as i was
talking to the news media back here i
kept saying where's the president
where's the president
where's the president
but he never came on
i knew he was going to come on and say
let's the violence has got to stop
but he didn't for four hours
later i asked my staff to pull the
records on what he was doing at that
time he was sitting in his dining room
next to the oval office
proud that these people would be in in
sacking the u.s capitol
beating up the capitol police officers
and he did nothing to stop it
in fact
20 minutes after they were in the
capitol
he tweeted out
mike pence doesn't have courage
my friends you can argue about whether
his speech that morning was incitement
or not but to me
that one tweet was incitement if they
had gotten hold of mike pence
we could have lost our democracy that
day
now if we had um some people are asking
the check is he telling the truth yeah
he's absolutely this is a republican
standing on stage in a congressional
primary he may very well have cost
himself his re-election here or yeah oh
absolutely well i mean i mean to
here's the thing here's the thing is
this guy is is going to be saddled with
the decision of what he just said now he
just said his in in his opinion um at
the ellipse that day donald trump's word
weren't may or may not have been
incitement but the tweet he did after
these insurrectionists who wanted to
overthrow our democracy and kill mike
pence right entered the capital he said
they sh basically in all sense of the
word he's viewing it as maybe they
should go get pence is what
representative rice is saying here and
he sees that as definite incitement that
they wanted to absolutely overturn our
democracy now here's the thing the
republicans the republican party uh
actually knows that this is the truth
right they know that this is the truth
there there's no i mean they've ever
said
it happened right and then they were
like well you know what we want to teach
them you know right i mean look at mitch
mcconnell right like he looked at he
said no we don't have the position of
the authority to impeach donald trump
which is like literally what you're
doing
uh and so you said okay boom as soon as
this is the vote is done and we've said
that we won't impeach him then mitch
mcconnell goes and says the
responsibility is on donald trump which
is obviously asked backwards from what
was just said and done by vote
but they know it was wrong they know
what happened
it's just whether they're willing to
continue to say it out loud or they've
said it once and they're like we've
already talked about it enough we got to
move on okay guys stop stop stop uh stop
focusing or stop pointing out that we
wanted to overthrow our constitution
right right yeah can you just like cool
it and just like move on to something
else just move up right move on that way
we can put donald trump back as
dictators so we don't have to talk about
this anymore listen
here's the point that i'm trying to make
by showing this video is that they're
not saying what rice is saying here
their party is actually saying the exact
opposite he is standing on stage this is
vitally important to our body politics
folks and this is why democrats
messaging is so important
it's so important
and you can see what they're terrified
of just in representative rice's words
here he is having defend the truth that
he saw with his own two [ __ ]
eyes and he heard with his ears and he
felt with his being inside that space of
the capital is that the truth is is that
they were trying to overturn our
democracy it was a coup
attempt it was an insurrection now
the body politic is saying that he has
to defend this on stage at a
congressional primary where he's going
to lose because he's saying this
folks
all these people on stage should be
saying the exact same thing i agree with
rice it was a coup attempt and and on
and on and on it would go to get votes
but they're not they're fighting him on
this
and that's because
they
the tale is wagging the dog at this
point q anon is a religion it is a cult
and they are taking over the body
politic of the republican party the
republican party that you once knew that
your dad and your grandpa were in
is no longer a thing it is gone it is
gone representative rice realizes it is
gone and even him who could who could
you know paint it up and icing this cake
and you know really really really sugar
coated here
is not and he knows he knows he's [ __ ]
if he's [ __ ] either way so he might as
well just tell the truth but republicans
we can't count on them to do this
because they're not doing this this is a
glimpse
a glimpse
into just an ounce of republican courage
here um and don't get too excited
because this is not going to keep
happening this is not going to keep
going they're going to oust these
candidates they're going to they're
going to vote in candidates like jd
vance who will kneel
kneel at the altar of america's hitler
not my words his words not my words he
called him america's hitler they are
going to bow and kneel at the altar of
american hitler so
thank you representative rice i guess
for having courage but here's the thing
if he really had some [ __ ] courage he
wouldn't be standing on this stage he
would leave the party right he would
leave the [ __ ] party so
you know and all in all i mean though
you could make the case that's like well
you know him versus another person who
would bow down before america's hitler
right like you could make the argument
that this guy while
the gop is not perfect and not great at
all he might be better than
someone else right i don't know who's
running uh in for that seat but you know
i'm not saying he should continue in
what he's doing
but
i don't know i i look at i'm like maybe
one is
better than the other
you know like that's the world we live
in like
well
you're putting me between a rock and a
hard place like which is the not as bad
one they're still bad but not as bad
right well i mean he's making a
calculation here and his calculation is
um i'm i'm saddled with this decision
that i made right so either i look like
a flip-flopping hypocrite or i just say
yeah that's exactly what i thought
that's exactly right you know he doesn't
want to appear to be a weak uh kevin
mccarthy in a week mitch mcconnell here
he wants to look principled which you
know congratulations to him his
principles suck right but he wants to
look 20 20 hindsight right right well it
happens another video i want to show you
gabe that everyone's uh been circulating
around you know lee mcgowan politics
girl she has a podcast on mind as touch
uh we're proud partners of of midas
touch um she did a video
uh i wanna she's also
gonna be on i i'm hoping i'm hoping i'm
hoping um that we can get leon to do
commentary uh so folks out there that
are lee mcgowan politics girl fans let
her know that do you want to hear her
her live commentary
uh for the public hearings uh for the
select january 6 select committee um
coming up in in the next month so um
definitely give her a shout out there to
say that you want to hear her commentary
but here is a little bit of her
commentary on the current issues stop
saying the democrats are just gonna lose
you know the entire world said the
ukrainians were just gonna lose but it
was inevitable that russia was just too
strong too big too powerful well that
was [ __ ] the ukrainians cared more
they fought back they were told to
surrender and they said hey russian
worship go [ __ ] yourselves and that is
what those of us who love democracy have
to say that's the energy we have to
embrace hey republican party go [ __ ]
yourselves you think you can cheat and
steal and lie and win you think you
could just take our rights from us and
our vote from us and our freedoms from
us and we're just gonna let you i don't
think so yeah i wish the democrats could
get their [ __ ] together and put together
a messaging platform that makes sense
that speaks to the moment but if they
can't we're just going to have to do it
without them just like the brave
ukrainian citizens fought back from
their own windows and made their own
volatile cocktails and acted like the
[ __ ] ballers that they were
democratic voters are not just going to
give up because everyone says we're
going gonna lose i'm fighting for
democracy for my own goddamn kitchen and
i know i'm not alone this country is
filled with patriots who won't just give
up democracy without a fight we are not
going to lose we can't lose we have to
come out in droves and convince our
people to come out in force to vote
against this sad pathetic backwards
racist homophobic xenophobic
misogynistic [ __ ] party banning
books and gays and women's rights this
anti-democratic party without values or
morals who wants to take your social
security and your medicare and to fund
our public schools and raise taxes on
the poor how can people even consider
voting for them what are they even
offering
we have to decimate this party and then
we have to start the hard work of
building up a country we can all be
proud of one that works for everyone
which is exactly what they are fighting
so hard to avoid but this change only
happens with the democrats the one party
who still believes in democracy i think
the republican party is bitten off more
than they can chew just like the
russians i think they've overplayed
their hand they think they're
untouchable but even with all their
cheating and lying and gerrymandering we
have to show them that they will never
defeat the idea of a free america with
liberty and justice for all
hey russian warship
go [ __ ] yourselves
[Laughter]
oh my god
she always has a way of packing like
10 hours worth of content here every
single week and i feel like that we try
to convey this message every single week
and she has a way of packing it into two
minutes
oh thank you lee for fighting for
democracy from your kitchen from your
microphone now i've been giving people
the messaging so subscribe to
politicsgirl go follow lee everywhere
you can um and listen her breakfast rant
videos are are fantastic as far as
messaging is concerned um gabe this is
this is an important and important time
yeah
and not just like to start this process
today but like tomorrow
next week next month we can't afford
to start this process and that is why it
is so important for people to yell and
scream in the streets even if it means
holding a bullhorn
in front of brett kavanaugh's house um
it is time to do that i want to show you
a video um uh midas jerry posted this on
her page
and i want to show you this is from a
speaking of people yelling and screaming
and protesting
this is at a better uh rally in texas
and people are getting pissed down there
in texas
they're ready to fight look at this
[Applause]
folks this isn't a couple dozen people
um trying to come out for beto o'rourke
um uh in texas this is hundreds of
people in every single venue every
single time he stops
um there is a movement happening in
texas and there should be movements
happening all around the country um in
in the fight for people's liberty and
boy
what what a time what a time to be a
part of history here
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right you guys don't have much
interest
so thank you thank you jerry for for
posting that video from the battle
campaign um midas robin
you're you're asking about the uh mika
berzynski's take on mitch can you can
you uh find that um video gabe i think
it's on msnbc see if you can find the
link to that video and minuses minus
robin's talking about that is that is a
good video i'd like to show too um thank
you jer minus jerry for the for the
video
um
again we like this show and react to
video here the other one gabe did you
see speaking of a protest um and not
just outside the
supreme court justice's house but here
is in new york
um and it's it's a bunch of american
force first end cells yelling back at
these protesters did you did you see
this did you actually i did see that
yeah so here like these guys
yeah i was just gonna say the you know
these macho
macho alpha guys going out there
literally saying
you know your body my choice right
they're pushing this like like not even
not even saying hey well you know we'll
let the court decide because the
decision hasn't been finalized obviously
though we know it's probably going to be
overturned right like the
the audacity
and the just overall [ __ ]
kind of
douchebag
persona
the madison the madison
squatch types right right exactly
just the fact that you know they they're
they're willing to stand you know these
women these people these men marching
are
again not doing anything to them they're
not bothering them they're not violating
them they're not infringing on their
rights they are walking marching
protesting and saying what they believe
and then you've got these guys who are
so
so fragile
so soft
so sensitive
that they have to then say that their
rights don't matter and their voice
doesn't matter right let's let's listen
to these america first in cells these
madison
cothorn asquatch tucker carlson tannier
balls nick fuentes nazi types
[Music]
[Applause]
your body not your body not your choice
your body is mine you're having my baby
is what this america verse and it's hard
to see here but these blue hats that
these these [ __ ] idiots are wearing
say america first on them gabe we've
seen this earlier in the broadcast you
remember where we seen this earlier in
the broadcast i happened to him i am
going to remember earlier nick fuentes
nick fascist fuentes let's let's see
nazi
yeah nick not nick nazi
i like that if you look down here at the
bottom here it says af
that doesn't mean as [ __ ] that means
america first yeah america first people
get it through your thick skulls let's
see what these wear these [ __ ]
boneheads on this on these steps where
they don't think it's the woman's choice
they don't think it's the woman's body
that they that this rapist apparently
aspiring rapist is you're going to for
i'm going to force you to have my baby
is what he said and that what you took
from a gabe that's what i took from it
that yeah
you're going to have my baby right
meanwhile everyone's like dude no one
wants to even make out with you right
right
right not within a hundred feet but he's
i
i mean i that's what i took from what he
said is he's aspiring to be a rapist he
wants to implant yeah his seed into
women enforcement i'm forcing my body
right onto yours right
i'm going to rape right and you're going
to have to have my child right now let's
see let's see what his leader his
messaging leader the republican party
messaging leader here has to say about
when a woman would be forced to carry
the term that rapist baby
if she were to abort it let's listen to
what his leader says about that the
woman should be put in jail too they
should all go to jail a hundred years
for the doctor a thousand years for the
woman that's what i say
so i wonder where that guy standing on
those steps got this idea that he could
just
he could just implant and it's almost
like he was
following watching listening i know it's
very someone
right like nick nazi fuentes tony gabe
it's ridiculous that you would play that
you would play
nick fuentes as the messaging leader of
the republican party this is crazy
you're out of your minds
you're out of your mind you'll never
overturn roe v wade tony and gabe get
the [ __ ] out of here here's here's
something here's something to think
about
if they want to come after things like
contraception condoms whatever right
they want they want to take it all the
way there what's to say
that this body of government these
republicans this supreme court wouldn't
be
exactly but these fascists wouldn't be
okay
with now going to somewhere like planned
parenthood or these other clinics where
they say give us your database of women
who have had abortions because now we're
going to retroactively
punish them
what's to say that wouldn't happen right
now i'm not saying that someone whoever
maintains the database says oops
it's all gone
like a true like a true patriot
but what's to say
that that they won't come after planned
parenthood and these other clinics to
say like hey give me give me the
database give me the people on your list
meanwhile just completely violating
hipaa law
uh
uh wouldn't go to them and say give me
the the log give me the list of people
the the list of women who have had
abortions
because i want to now come after them
for murder
right they're doing it in texas they're
doing it
making a felony to leave the state to
have a medical procedure look
mika brzezinski breaks this down here i
believe this is the uh the the uh the
video but mitch mcconnell said the other
day that he wouldn't he would not be
surprised if there was a national
abortion ban which is not states rights
that's not a states rights stance when
you have a fascist federal government
right uh like republicans keeping
control taking away at the state's
rights away i mean it's it's in total
contradiction to the [ __ ] they're
saying today and that is the [ __ ] rub
with fascists as they're always in
contradiction of themselves because
really fascist ideology does not make
sense when you couple it with freedom
when you're trying to form this message
of freedom and equality and rights and
our constitution our constitution
is the reason why
you fascist out there the reason why it
feels like the constitution is against
you is because it is
it is written against you and we have
progressed the constitution that living
document to [ __ ] vehemently be
against you right let's listen to what
mika says here i believe this is the
clip that everyone's uh
talking about so i'm sorry i the the old
white guys yeah this is it
mitch is gonna tell us what the story of
the day is he's gonna tell us what the
story of the day is
that's rich mitch you're going to tell
us
about the rights the 50 years of rights
the 50 decades of president that has
just been spit on
i want to point out when she says i want
to back it up a bit because when she's
like when she says that mitch it almost
she wanted to say she wanted to say it
so she's on the msnbc so she can't say
it but i will say it here for mika she
wanted to say
right i [ __ ]
so yeah [ __ ] mcconnell right [ __ ]
we're gonna listen it's gonna tell us
what the story of the day is he's gonna
tell us what the story of the day is
that's rich
mitch
that's rich
[ __ ] that's totally what i thought she
was going to say there was like a half
second pause like
mitch she was going to say [ __ ] she
wanted to say [ __ ] she wanted and she's
totally in her right to say that right
even joe thought he's like oh my god
she's going to say [ __ ]
totally 100 100 let's listen to what
mika and how she buries him here the
president that has just been spit on and
thrown away in this draft opinion might
be tweaked a little bit
but
the bottom line is this is
setting women back
in so many different ways with so many
different consequences and you're going
to tell us that the story is the leak
really the leak is fascinating it's
historic it's never happened before and
whoever did it it's interesting because
i think we're going to find out who did
it i think some people already know who
did it i think actually they're going to
be the the talking point of the leak is
going to be crushed going to be crushed
when we find out who actually did the
leak i i believe that is the actual
story behind the leak if you want to
know the truth i think she's alluding to
it here is that
people do know and people the whispers
are out there of who leaked this thing
and when we find out and confirm it and
it is true the fascists are gonna be
like oh don't ignore the ignore the leak
ignore the leak the leak is not the
story the story is is that they're
bullying they're they're they're trying
to commit an insurrection on the supreme
court that's to be their next narrative
let's listen
and i think a lot of people are already
alluding to who did it and it's not who
you think mitch
but even if it is that's not the story
we care about okay
the story that women across america and
the men who love them
or the men who might like sex care about
is our fundamental right to abortion
that this draft opinion overturns
and that's the story just to give you a
sense of news judgment
and what people care about
that's what they care about just
i just had to say that i'm sorry i i
that was disgusting that was sickening
to watch
to tell us what the story is
to tell the press what the story is to
tell us women who are the focus of this
story
our rights what happens to us our health
care our daughters our sisters
our mothers you're going to tell us what
the story is it's a leak in the supreme
court it's fascinating it's
unprecedented and there is a fantastic
trail to be followed there and it should
be
because that shouldn't happen
chief justice john roberts even said
that
it's a story but it's not the story you
know gabe the one thing um i think about
this leak thing and mika's talking about
here thank you robin for pointing that
uh that clip out
here's the thing it is really [ __ ]
weird that justice roberts the minute
that a leak happens he's like
investigation let's find out that genie
thomas may or may not have leaked this
but when
but when the same person who may or may
have not elite this i don't know it's a
legend right right may or may not
believe this
is [ __ ] uh
texting the chief of staff of the
president united states the wife of a
supreme court justice to try to overturn
a coup and then that justice votes
in in support of that insurrection
he's like crickets [ __ ] crickets no
investigation ah that's not that's
that's not historic the leak on the
other hand of taking away human rights
away from people in this country that's
historic and that needs to be
investigated but the fact that uh one of
our supreme court justices may and his
wife may or may not have tried to undo
the constitution that that doesn't
warrant any kind of investment the fact
that the highest court in the land the
most respected court in the land
supposedly may be tainted it's like
listen we all knew this because the
federal society but the fact that now
it's on a public scale and they're like
it might be it might be tainted because
somebody leaked it oh my god and then
willingly and the same breath go yeah
jenny she ain't she cool
she cool yeah no nothing wrong with her
nothing to see here nothing to see here
right
you know um gabe we are 53 minutes into
the second hour i also want to say this
i also want to say this
i don't know if many people are saying
it
but i might be under the belief that
maybe maybe not clarence thomas or one
of his clerks leaked it as a means
of distracting from anything that came
before it right oh you're saying you're
saying so you're saying the fact that
that maybe someone finds out that
someone possibly could have done this
leak that that would distract from other
crimes that may have been committed is
that what you're saying yeah that's what
i'm saying yeah you know i heard people
say that i just heard you say that so
many people are saying let's listen
folks at the politics girl the video
that we watched earlier makes a good
point and we have to we have to if you
want your country if you want your
democracy it is time to fight it is time
to fight with messaging um these
fascists do it all the time they do it
fox news they do it with they do it with
disinformation misinformation and lies
we can do it with the truth the truth is
is that jeannie thomas we've seen the
text messages right out in the open the
facts she was she's a cueing on her
she's nuttier than [ __ ] squirrel
turds yep
she was texting the chief of staff to
try to get the president united states
to undo our constitution she was in
support of the q anon cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
that is a fact we are not making this
[ __ ] up we don't have to make this [ __ ]
up they do it for us but for us not to
talk about it like they're [ __ ]
looney tunes and to make sure that
jeannie thomas is clarence thomas
they share a bed they share a house they
share a marriage yeah you're gonna tell
me they did not discuss any of this
out of here
right roe v wade you didn't tell me when
they were doing their evening prayers at
the right at the bedside that they
weren't saying hey listen so clarence
i'm thinking about overthrowing the
government and he's like oh jenny no no
no we're not going to overthrow the
government we're going to overturn roe
first babe that's what we're going to do
yeah we're going to we're going to take
away women's rights first and then the
right to vote and then we'll have a
really good fascist state going on and
we won't have to commit a cheeto dusk
kangaroo i wouldn't be surprised if
those two had a vision board i would
love to see what their vision board
looks like maybe maybe it'll show up on
the internet at some point well maybe
but a vision board that has all of these
like newspaper clippings and like
magazine stuff and words that just
basically says like roe v wade uh
insurrection like all these things that
they plan to do like 2022 that's gonna
be our year it's on the vision board
it's what we want to happen
the q anon vision board is that what
you're saying yeah yeah well you know it
could happen again i'm not saying that
exactly what happened but i wouldn't be
surprised if something was strategically
done to distract from something else
that's right but we have to get that
messaging out there that's a great
message you know another good message
and i've been saying this for weeks and
weeks if you're out there and you're in
your community whether it's your church
your school your pta meeting at the
grocery store for crying out loud at
your family dinners you should ask the
question just start the conversation by
asking this question did you hear
republicans in florida are trying to ban
math holy [ __ ] that will start the
conversation and folks you have to
continue
it is up to us just like politics girls
said
democrats may or may not adopt a good
message here right they may or may not
be willing to go as far as we will go to
save our democracy fine whatever if the
party doesn't find whatever we must and
we must you must you must activate you
must engage you must do everything you
can not just tweet but get in the street
and yell and scream with your your your
megaphones uh protest because here's the
thing fascist we've learned this in the
last few days fascists are absolutely
terrified terrified of women with
megaphones gabe they are they are
absolutely i mean this is scary stuff
brett kavanaugh is crying
under his bed right now i would imagine
imagine the terror of a woman with a
loud voice holy [ __ ] oh my god that is
the kind of thing that kills fascists so
keep doing it folks keep killing
fascists with your voice with your music
with your song with your protest go out
there support these candidates get to
them
give money give money i know sometimes
it's hard to give but anything you can
give to these to these folks to win
these races so that we can fight for our
democracy up and down the ballot it is
so so
important that we get in good trouble
here just like politics girl was saying
um it is so important so important that
we get in good trouble every single day
and that's what we're gonna do here gabe
every single weekday monday through
friday two hours a day youtube twitter
twitch go follow us the tony michaels
podcast
we are going to get in good trouble we
also do good trouble by simulcasting to
the midas touch facebook page follow us
everywhere you can facebook youtube
twitter just type in the tony michaels
podcast or go to thetonymichaels.com you
will find it
you will find it and we will be here
tomorrow causing good [ __ ] trouble
some really good
[ __ ] trouble as we do every day yep
gabe
every single day so
the [ __ ] hits the fan and we are here to
just [ __ ] make a mess of things right
yeah you gotta you gotta take that [ __ ]
and smear it all the wall apparently
yeah just say yeah that was good trouble
i'm just following the republicans leave
at that time that's it we gotta we gotta
we gotta [ __ ] smear people yeah we gotta
clown these [ __ ] and we will do
it every single weekday here on the tony
michaels podcast until tomorrow
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking